[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono sempre stata affascinata dal caos
dalla teoria del caos e quando ho
cominciato a studiare fisica ero
completamente presa da qualsiasi cosa
riguardasse il caos da tutte quelle
operazioni fatte per creare ordine dal
disordine e disordine dall'ordine
per preparare il discorso Oggi però ho
cercato in rete la definizione di caos e
Cito Treccani nelle antiche cosmologie
greche il caos e il complesso degli
elementi materiali senza ordine che
preesiste all'universo ordinato nella
stessa frase ho trovato due parole a me
tantissimo care caos e universo
e oggi sono qui a parlarvi di caos e
universo grandissimi fisici si sono
occupati della teoria del caos tra cui
anche Edoardo Amaldi Edoardo Amaldi è
stato anche di uno dei Padri fondatori
della ricerca per le onde gravitazionali
e io voglio parlarvi di caos e onde
gravitazionali Ma cosa sono le onde
relazionali Forse avete sentito parlare
delle Correnti gravitazionali nella
bellissima canzone di Franco Battiato La
cura definiamo le onde gravitazionali
delle piccole increspature dello spazio
tempo mandiamo con ordine Einstein Oltre
100 anni fa predisse che lo spazio e il
tempo si fondono
più che una predizione era diciamo una
necessità avere una geometria nuova che
non coinvolgesse solo lo spazio ma anche
il tempo era fondamentale per spiegare
alcuni fenomeni della fisica
sempre Einstein disse che questo spazio
tempo in presenza di una grande Massa
può incurvarsi e la gravità non è
nient'altro che la manifestazione di
questa curvatura
disse anche che se queste masse si
mettono in movimento Magari hanno anche
una forma strana tipo quella di
un'anguria e cominciano a ruotare
possono generare delle onde le onde
gravitazionali Avete presente quando
lanciate un sasso in uno stagno quelle
piccole ondine che si creano Ecco
immaginate che adesso quello stagno sia
lo spazio tempo e il sasso sia un sole o
una massa 10 volte 20 volte grande
quando il sole
queste onde possono essere create grazie
alla presenza di queste grandi masse ma
sono estremamente deboli Einstein che
pure l'aveva predette disse che non
saremo mai stati in grado di rivelarli
proprio per questa ampiezza piccola e
per questo motivo Noi siamo stati
costretti a guardare l'universo dove ci
sono stelle che mangiano altre stelle
buchi neri che inghiottono stelle stelle
che decidono di esplodere diffondersi e
tutti questi fenomeni catastrofici
possono emettere onde gravitazionali
Ma come abbiamo fatto a rivelarle
l'idea è semplice quando un'onda
gravitazionale passa può mettere in
oscillazione delle masse libere Quindi
abbiamo deciso di sfruttare questa
questa conseguenza del passaggio della
Neve rottazionale abbiamo deciso di
misurare l'oscillazione di queste masse
libere solo che nel nostro caso le masse
libere sono degli specchi e il metro con
cui misuriamo questa oscillazione e un
laser un laser estremamente stabile
sapevamo grazie ad altri fisici che
avevano fatto dei compiti teorici o
delle simulazioni numeriche Che tipo di
segnale stavamo cercando perché le onde
Non sono caotiche si producono un
segnale ben definito Noi l'abbiamo
definito cip cinguettio perché il suono
che avrebbe generato sarebbe stato
simile a quello di un uccello
il problema come vi dicevo era che sono
estremamente deboli
nei fisici li abbiamo passato 50 anni a
cercarle perché noi fisici siamo così ci
innamoriamo ci innamoriamo di un'idea ci
innamoriamo della Bellezza dell'universo
che magari è racchiuso in una formula
una formula semplice che qualche pazzo
decide anche di scrivere su un treno
abbandonato nel deserto del Cile oppure
che come me si emoziona quando la trova
scritta all'interno all'ingresso di un
istituto di fisica abbiamo creato questi
rivelatori sempre più sensibili perché
come vi dicevo il segnale estremamente
debole quindi dobbiamo creare uno
strumento estremamente silenzioso
c'è una grandissima tecnologia dietro
questi rivelatori abbiamo dovuto fare
delle Degli Specchi estremamente puliti
un laser ultra stabile mettere tutto
sottovuoto E renderlo tutto estremamente
silenzioso quello che vedete poi nel
video a sinistra c'è una simulazione di
questo
esperimento mentre a destra c'è quello
che abbiamo creato perché perché tutto
questo energia tutto questo sforzo per
cercare di relazionali potrei dirvi per
niente non servono a nulla domani
mattina nessuno di noi accenderà la
macchina grazie alla neve Nazionale O si
farà un caffè alla velocità della luce
Ma pensate a quando oltre un secolo fa i
fisici della scuola di Copenaghen
passavano notte giorno a scrivere
formule su formule stavano inventando la
meccanica quantistica sembrava una cosa
talmente lontana dalla realtà Eppure
grazie alla meccanica quantistica che
oggi che possiamo utilizzare un laser
possiamo fare una risonanza magnetica
possiamo bombardare un tumore Quindi
anche se la ricerca la fisica teorica
sembra così lontano dalla realtà è un
investimento un investimento che
facciamo nel nostro futuro e tutti i
paesi e tutti i paesi dovrebbero
investire in questa ricerca perché
quello che oggi se non sembra avere
un'applicazione pratica lo avrà anche la
relatività generale quella scritta in
quella bellissima formula ha
un'applicazione pratica senza le
correzioni fatte grazie a quella formula
Non avreste una misura il GPS preciso
come l'avete ora sul cellulare è proprio
grazie a questa formula che tutto
funziona
ma torniamo
all'argomento principale della del mio
Talk perché è stato importante il caos
per questa la scoperta come vi dicevo il
lo strumento è estremamente silenzioso
abbiamo fatto un modo tale che tutti i
disturbi esterni contribuissero poco a
rumore a creare rumore Dobbiamo ottenere
avere la macchina il più silenziosa
possibile ma nonostante questo il nostro
strumento sente dei rumori sente il
passaggio di una macchina vicino un
evento elettromagnetico la tempesta il
vento persino le onde del mare e questo
rumore Ha il brutto vizio di mettersi in
un ordine preciso questa curva che
vedete alle mie spalle non è il segnale
che stiamo cercando Questo è il rumore
rumore ordinatissimo all'interno di
questo rumore c'è il nostro segnale il
segnale gravitazionale quello che
stavamo cercando voi non lo potete
vedere Avete presente quando vi fanno
quei test in cui vi chiedono di trovare
un unico elemento fuori posto in una
marea di numeri uguali
È complicato perché sarete ipnotizzati
da questa marea di numero uguali ma
provate a fare l'operazione opposta
Provate a rimescolare questi numeri
lasciando fermo solo il numero che state
cercando sarà molto più facile metterlo
in evidenza Ecco noi abbiamo fatto più o
meno un'operazione simile abbiamo preso
il nostro rumore e l'abbiamo rimescolato
siamo passati da questa curva precisa a
questa disordinata Questo è il rumore
caotico all'interno di questo rumore
però c'è ancora il nostro segnale
piccolo e non si riesce a vedere ma
Permettetemi di fare una magia passiamo
da questo questa rappresentazione del
nostro segnale a una rappresentazione
diversa quella che nel nostro dominio si
chiama rappresentazione tempo frequenza
Trasformiamo questi dati in un'immagine
quella che vedete alle mie spalle
non è il cuore al segnale quella linea
rossa che vedete è ancora il rumore
sempre bello preciso ordinato Facciamo
la stessa cosa sui dati che abbiamo
mescolato che abbiamo reso caotici ed
ecco qua quello che vedete quel chip
quello è un segnale di onde
gravitazionale siamo riusciti a metterlo
in evidenza solo grazie alla creazione
del caso ad averli mescolato i nostri
dati
e questo è quello che succede Questo è
quello che noi fisici delle onde
relazionali facciamo quotidianamente per
cercare i nostri segnali sappiamo che
tipo di forma d'onda dobbiamo cercare il
famoso cinguettio che ha quella
rappresentazione oppure questa ma vi
spiego voglio raccontarvi un po' come è
andata ormai si sa le onde relazionale
le abbiamo rivelate nel 2015
cercavamo questo segnale qua era un
pomeriggio di settembre erano nel mio
ufficio e insieme ad altri colleghi
Ricevo una mail del mio amico collega
Marco Drago che era all'epoca postdocca
dal 9 che ci dice Guardate nei dati C'è
qualcosa di strano c'è questa roba qua
c'è questo segnale e io ricordo che la
prima cosa che feci fu scrivere su Skype
a Marco perdigli o Ma ci stai prendendo
in giro in realtà Diciamo che il
linguaggio era un po' più colorito
eravamo completamente stupiti dal fatto
che il nostro rivelatore avesse trovato
questo segnale
era bellissimo perché era esattamente
come Einstein aveva predetto come i
fisici teorici l'avevano simulato e come
noi avevamo fatto in modo tale che
l'esperimento fosse in grado di
rivelarlo
non ci credevamo e era esattamente
uguale alla predizione
e per questo motivo abbiamo messo in
atto proprio un'indagine investigativa
il segnale l'abbiamo
rivelato a settembre ma ne abbiamo dato
notizia a febbraio perché abbiamo messo
impiegato tutti questi mesi per
verificare che esattamente avevamo fatto
la prima scoperta di onde relazionale da
allora ne abbiamo trovati altri 90 di
segnali simili ma ogni volta ci
emozioniamo ogni volta aggiungiamo un
po' di conoscenza ai misteri
dell'universo adesso È proprio notizia
di questi giorni Abbiamo ricominciato a
prendere dati scientifici giusto tre
giorni fa e ci aspettiamo di trovarne
altri e di emozionarci ancora di fronte
a queste scoperte non sappiamo neanche
cosa ci rivela ancora l'universo
perché noi fisici siamo così ci
innamoriamo ci innamoriamo di un'idea di
una formula semplice e possiamo passare
anni secoli in un loop
formuliamo una teoria Costruiamo
l'esperimento per verificarla
analizziamo i dati per confermarla e il
lupo di una bellezza straordinaria di
cui ha avuto l'onore e la fortuna di
farne parte
per partecipare a questa scoperta
bellissima della fisica degli ultimi
anni abbiamo dovuto creare il caos
quindi non vi preoccupate Se dovete
creare il caos nella vostra vita se
dovete rimescolare i numeri se dovete
attraversarli perché ogni numero di
mescolato può essere fondamentale per
realizzare i vostri sogni
[Musica]